un bon soir le début d'une nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez dans
cette édition du lundi et 8 février
voici les titres de ce journal son
histoire a été médiatisé dans les
dernières semaines depuis novembre
didier lemaire est placée sous
protection policière ce professeur de
philosophie de trappes a été menacé
suite à la publication d'une lettre
ouverte dans la presse dénonçant la
progression du communautarisme
c'était en novembre quelques jours après
l'assassinât de samuel potier à conflans
sainte honorine les universités s'ouvre
à nouveau étudiants les établissements
de l'enseignement supérieur avait la
possibilité dès aujourd'hui de
réaccueillir en présentiel leurs élèves
le tout dans la limite de 20 % de leurs
capacités nous étions ce matin la
faculté de droit de sciences politiques
de l'ue vs q et puis le déplacement
aujourd'hui de la ministre désormais à
rambouillet florence parly est venu
lancer officiellement le nouveau système
de soldes des militaires sur ce sol doit
corriger les problèmes de l'ancien
logiciel nous voit à l'origine de
retards et des erreurs de paiement qui
ont touché des dizaines de milliers de
militaires et puis invité à suivre
également dans cette édition françois
morton vice président de saint quentin
en yvelines pour parler du nouveau
programme de soutien de l'agglomération
en faveur des aidants familiaux
elle visait par des propos violents
didier lemaire enseignants à trappes est
aujourd'hui placée sous protection
policière des propos qui inquiète les
autorités d'autant que cet enseignant
s'est exprimé à plusieurs reprises
publiquement pour dénoncer une
radicalisation religieuse dans sa
commune il évoque un terreau un
territoire je cite est définitivement
perdue les précisions dans ce sujet de
wilfrid richy célia gars de son go
justin de raser et patrick jacques de
dixmude je penserai professeurs ils sont
là pour éduquer les enfants leur
apprendre des choses
pas la peine de les menacer je pense
mais la plupart des parents la grande
majorité des parents trappe fonte ou par
leurs enfants soient bien éduqué dans
l'aber veillance depuis quelques jours
les habitants de trappes découvre une
nouvelle fois que leur commune fait la
une des médias nationaux la raison cet
article publié vendredi soir par nos
confrères du point
et qui donne la parole à didier lemaire
professeur de philosophie au lycée de la
plaine de neauphle depuis une vingtaine
d'années didier lemaire il fait part de
ses inquiétudes évoque un
communautarisme religieux de plus en
plus présent une emprise islamistes
forte qui ne lui permettent plus
d'exercer sa profession dans le respect
des principes républicains
aujourd'hui il ya des atteintes à la
laïcité qui ne sont pas simplement des
actes individuels mais vraiment des
actes de pressions répétées collective
par exemple en début d'année dans une
classe des élèves
l'ensemble des filles de la classe qui
refusent une sortie scolaire au prétexte
qu'elles seront filmés sans leur sens
leur voile donc c'est cette
transformation finalement à l'intérieur
même de l'école
kiki cliente qui empiète sur notre notre
liberté pédagogique
placé depuis quelques semaines sous
protection policière didier lemaire
serait la cible de menaces sur les
réseaux sociaux après une première prise
de parole dans les médias au lendemain
de l'assassinât du professeur samuel
pâtit une lettre ouverte publiée dans
l'obs qui avait interpellé au delà de
nos frontières
en témoigne ce reportage d'une
télévision néerlandaise elle ne peut que
s'interroger
enduit sur l'avenir de notre métier
comment enseigner les langues les arts
les sciences et la culture générale
à des enfants qui sont soumis dès leur
plus jeune âge à la pression sociale
phénoménale de ces idéologues alors que
la loi contre le séparatisme est à
l'étude à l'assemblée nationale ces
déclarations largement fait réagir dans
les rangs politiques à commencer par le
député de la circonscription
je pense à tous les trois de la
république qui doivent aussi subir des
menaces et et rencontré de grosses
difficultés dans leur dans leur métier
et c'est pour ça que nous dans la loi
dite de séparatistes à l'assemblée
nationale avec le groupe l'est
républicain on veut renforcer cette loi
pour pouvoir protéger davantage protéger
davantage les enseignants et tu voudrais
vous dire aussi que j'aimerais qu'un
jour dans les médias on puisse parler en
bien de trappes et pas toujours gagner
un problème maire de trappes en attente
de son recours auprès du conseil d'état
après l'invalidation de son élection à
les rabais estime que malgré tout
certaines déclarations de didier lemaire
sont infondées
je défends le droit et la liberté
d'expression de tout le monde y compris
de didier lemaire et y compris pour
raconter de l'insanité d'accord je lui
refuse le droit de me diffamer c'est
pour ça que j'irai dans les tribunaux
mais je l'autorisent à raconter ce qu'il
veut y compris des mensonges y compris
qu'il n'y a pas de quartier ouvert aux
femmes y compris qu'il n'y a pas de
coiffeur ouvert aux femmes
on a le droit dans ce pays de raconter
ce que l'on souhaite une vision sans
doute partagé par les acteurs sur le
terrain de plusieurs associations mais
qui ne pourraient masquer ce chiffre 67
jeune originaire de trappes sont partis
en irak ou en syrie entre 2014 et 2016
quant à l'académie de versailles elle
indique avoir reçu ce lundi didier
lemaire et que ce dernier a exprimé le
souhait de rester enseigné à trappes est
les conditions de son maintien sur place
seront étudiés avec la préfecture des
yvelines et dans l'actualité l'épidémie
de kovy de 19 avec une situation qui
reste tendu sur le territoire regarder
ces derniers chiffres collectés sur une
semaine à part pour le taux de
positivité tous les autres indicateurs
sont encore à la hausse et les nouvelles
contaminations pour 100000 habitants ce
qu'on appelle le taux d'incidence a
augmenté de 9 points à l'hôpital la
tension se dégrade avec plus de patients
qui occupent les lits de réanimation 45
personnes supplémentaires ont été
hospitalisés dans les yvelines depuis le
31 janvier a depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire 1254 personnes
combes et aux copies de 19 et dans les
établissements de santé du département
l'épidémie qui touche aussi de plus en
plus les écoles il y a deux semaines le
collège alexandre dumas à maurepas fermé
ses portes après la révélation sur place
d'une trentaine de cas positifs dont
certains provenant des variants en tout
dans le département ce sont 17 places
qui ont été fermés sur recommandation de
la rs et dont récemment une école à la
derrière les vacances d'hiver débutent
pour rappel à la fin de la semaine pour
les écoliers de la zone c à l'université
les cours continuent de reprendre
progressivement les établissements sont
autorisés à réaccueillir sur place 20 %
de leurs effectifs
après les étudiants en grande précarité
et les premières années la faculté de
droit et de science politique de
l'université versailles saint quentin a
choisi de donner cette possibilité à ses
autres étudiants celle de reprendre les
enseignements de travaux dirigés le
reportage de mélanie poquet et
d'eléonore sinoquet d'une trentaine
d'étudiants à une quinzaine les travaux
dirigés ce faux en tous petits groupes
l'université versailles saint quentin
accueille à nouveau ses étudiants depuis
ce lundi 8 février
pour ces 2e année leur premier cours de
droit pénal se fait en présentiel le
fait déjà de voir les professeurs parce
que c'est pas du tout les mêmes choses
qu'on est chez nous toute la journée en
jogging et eau et de revoir les autres
si ça peut vraiment je viens d'avoir un
lien social parce que vraiment depuis
trois mois tout seul dans sa chambre
c'est pas super même si j'habite loin
j'ai fait plus d'une heure de trajet
pour venir les je me dis que ça vaut le
coup parce que ça est vraiment
pour mieux comprendre le court le
contact avec les professeurs et avec
d'autres étudiants plutôt que rester
seul chez soi c'est moins sympa un
retour fait sur la base du volontariat
pour cette première journée ils sont 300
à pouvoir revenir dans les salles de
cours
la visio est toujours proposé cette
filière accueille en temps normal trois
mille étudiants vraiment les travaux
dirigés sont des cours en petits groupes
dans lesquels une interaction est
vraiment possible entre les étudiants
entre eux et également entre les
étudiants et les lors des enseignants
c'est vraiment en td un mode
d'enseignement qui est vraiment propice
à l'interaction et vous fait que l'on
peut se nourrir des échanges les cours
magistraux sont dispensés en
visioconférence les étudiants se voient
aussi proposer une archive film est bien
qu espérer un retour à la normale n'est
pas encore envisagée par l'université
est ce lundi matin florence parly s'est
rendu aux services du commissariat des
armées c'est à rambouillet la ministre
des armées a annoncé sur place le
passage définitif au nouveau système de
soldes des militaires
l'objectif assurer et faciliter le
paiement des rémunérations des soldats
désormais française nicolas d'andré le 8
février 2021 fera date dans la gestion
des ressources humaines de l'armée
française le passage définitif au
logiciel source soldes pour la
rémunération des 250 mille militaires
après la marine au printemps 2010 9
l'armée de terre en mai 2020 c'est au
tour de l'armée de l'air et de l'espace
et au service de santé des armées
d'intégrer ce système une plateforme
internet plus efficace pour le militaire
il va y trouver les informations sur son
bulletin de solde mais surtout ça qui
est très intéressant tout ce qui a été
utilisé par le calculateur pour calculer
la solde il peut donc très rapidement
dira j'ai un enfant qui n'a pas été
déclaré monty nouveau n'est pas encore
déclaré
donc à pouvoir se retourner vers son
administrant pour lui dire attention il
ya un oubli l'entreprise sopra steria a
été choisi par le ministère des armées
la direction générale de l'armement a
piloté ce projet depuis 2015 ce dossier
fait suite à l'échec du calculateur
louvois responsable du versement de 700
millions d'euros de soldes indue des
rémunérations qui ont été récupérés
ensuite par l'administration
l'objectif de sources solde est double
assurer la fiabilité et simplifier le
calcul nous avons cette année en 2021
commencé de mettre en place cette
nouvelle politique de rémunération des
militaires avec une première indemnité
qui est beaucoup plus simple qui
remplace un grand nombre d'indemnités
pour qu'un militaire qui s'engagent
fortement qui se déploie souvent sur un
théâtre d'opérations à l'extérieur comme
sur le territoire national puisse en
voir rapidement et de façon lisible la
traduction sur sa feuille de sol
comprise dans la loi de programmation
militaire cette réforme de la
rémunération des militaires va se
poursuivre sur les deux prochaines
années mais la crue de la seine toujours
au coeur de l'actualité yvelinoise a
également les précipitations du week-end
n'ont pas fait redescendre le niveau du
fleuve le département reste pour l'heure
en vigilance jaune aux inondations la
scène est sortie de son lit en plusieurs
endroits inondant les quais jardin et
route à proximité directe comme vous le
voyez sur ces images tournées par célia
400 go à carrières sous poissy et à
poissy
dans cette dernière commune le niveau
est monté à 21 m 68 soit 4 m 68 au
dessus de la cote habituelle et cette
montée devrait se poursuivre est la
ville a conseillé aux habitants de
l'idée mignot de quitter leurs
habitations au vu de la situation
en france 11 millions de personnes sont
considérées comme aidants familiaux une
charge lourde qui a pu le devenir encore
plus avec la crise sanitaire les aidants
ont dû parfois eux-mêmes assurer la
continuité des soins de leur proche
malade ou dépendant
face à ce constat l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines propose
plusieurs services on en parle et
françois morton bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le maire de la commune de
guyancourt également vice-présidente
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
la politique de la ville de la santé et
de la solidarité
on va parler de ces actions est mise en
place au travers de lits ps lille ps
c'est à l'institut de promotion de la
santé qui est basée à trappes il met en
oeuvre la politique de santé local sur
un accueil pour informer et regroupe
aussi les acteurs médico-sociaux locaux
on va parler avec vous un de ce nouveau
programme de soutien lancée déjà
pourquoi cette mobilisation de
l'agglomération en faveur des aidants
familiaux
bah écoutez vous l'avez un petit peu
évoquée à ces aidants familiaux ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux
et en cette période sanitaire n'a pu
effectivement déterminé que les besoins
étaient réelles et de plus en plus
importants et son onze concerts pardon ô
combien de personnes sont concernées par
par cette thématique à 50 ans nuit
combien de personnes sont considérées
comme aidants familiaux
justement alors c'est assez compliqué de
déterminer mais on peut en avoir une
petite idée aux travailleurs de certains
indicateurs
lors de nos actions du premier trimestre
de l'année 2020 on a pu par exemple
recensé environ 200 personnes qui ont
été concernés par nos actions et du coup
en quoi est ce nécessaire de les
soutenir je le disais tout à l'heure
c'est des personnes qui ont pu se sentir
seul avec la crise sanitaire qui a
exacerbé toutes ces choses
parfois dépassés sur le plan physique et
mosson émotionnel social est aussi
financier il ya plein d'aspects qui sont
recoupées avec cette thématique des
aidants familiaux souvent être aidant
familial c'est un travail à temps
complet on accompagne une personne est
le postulat départ de ce plan d'action
qui a été mis en oeuvre pour les
accompagner c'est de se dire que pour
être un aidant familial
j'ai envie de dire efficace et et
bienveillant et accueillant il faut être
soi même en bonne santé qu'elle soit
physique ou psychique
alors je le disais il ya un programme de
soutien lancée par l'agglomération avec
une nouveauté qui s'appelle le passe
temps libre quel est le principe
alors ce passe temps libre et ils
rentrent dans le cadre de ce que l'on
appelle le regli ces personnes qui sont
souvent pendant très longtemps
à côté de ces personnes qui sont souvent
dépendantes que ce soit lié à la maladie
au handicap ou au grand âge elles ont
besoin aussi de temps pour elles mêmes
et donc c'est vraiment en partant de ce
postulat qu'on s'est dit comment comment
peut-on permettre à ces personnes de
s'accorder du temps pour elles mêmes et
donc d'être relayé auprès des personnes
dont elle s'occupe habituellement
donc l'idée c'est de pouvoir
leur proposer serez pied alors ce passe
temps libre c'est fait avec une
entreprise qui a été incubés à saint
quentin en yvelines au ski cube seo
d'avis c'est ça oui absolument ces taux
d'avis qui est ce prestataire de
d'accompagnement et d'aidé à la personne
et justement pouvoir souffler un peu
est-ce que c'est primordial d'avoir
cette possibilité justement d'avoir ce
répit ce oui c'est primordial c'est à
dire que et ce qui est intéressant avec
ce passe temps libre c'est que l'on part
réellement des besoins de l'aidant or
ces besoins ils peuvent ils peuvent être
divers et variés encore une fois c'est
avoir du temps pour soi ça peut être
avoir du temps pour effectuer des
démarches pour soi même des démarches
administratives ou d'aller chez le
coiffeur ou de faire du sport et c'est
ça qui est important dans ce passe temps
libre c'est qu'on est au plus proche des
besoins de ces aidants et c'est gratuit
ce passe temps libre oui c'est tout à
fait gratuit
alors il ya d'autres actions aussi un an
plus de ce passe temps libre qui
existait déjà les entrées dans le café
on proposera d'ailleurs dans nos
éditions du journal cette semaine un
reportage sur le sujet l'idée c'est
autour d'un café
une rencontre avec des sujets différents
abordé l'idée c'est de s'informer
d'échanger de créer du lien et aussi les
groupes de paroles et de soutien pour
partager un vécu une problématique ça
c'est rendez vous ils ont été maintenus
malgré la crise sanitaire c'était une
nécessité de pouvoir les maintenir
alors ils ont été interrompus
effectivement au moment du premier
confinement il avait bien fonctionné
durant le premier trimestre de l'année
2020 ils ont pu tous reprendre ces
rendez-vous alors souvient souvent avec
de nouvelles modalités bien évidemment
et notamment à distance à partir du mois
de novembre
mais on a pu effectivement touché alors
bien évidemment pas comme on l'aurait
souhaité et hors période
de crise sanitaire mais en tout cas
elles ont pu quand même se dérouler sur
la fin d'année ce début d'année
et j'ajoute aussi j'avais pas précisé
qu'il ya des ateliers thématiques qui
sont proposés avec de la détente de la
mise en pratique de conseil est aussi
d'aider partage de moments conviviaux
une question très pratique pour terminer
pour y prendre part à ces actions si on
souhaite pouvoir en bénéficier
comment fait-on est ce qu'on prend
contact directement avec lee ps
l'institut de promotion de la santé avec
lee ps absolument vous l'avais dit en ce
qui concerne le passe temps libre on
peut aussi aller se renseigner
s'informer auprès du site de davie 78 et
toutes les informations sur le lien qui
va peut-être s'affiche en bas de l'écran
ça y est ils s'affichent sur le site de
saint quentin en yvelines yvelines
pardon rubrique services et vie pratique
merci françois morton d'avoir été avec
nous merci et bonne soirée de la commune
de guyancourt et vice président de saint
quentin en yvelines en charge de la
politique de la ville est de la santé et
de la solidarité
à voisins le bretonneux s'éteint un
projet attendu depuis vingt ans les
travaux de la zac de la remise débuté
l'été dernier se poursuivent le point
sur l'avancée de ce chantier de ce futur
écoquartier avec eléonore sinoquet
mélanie poker et astrid bergère d'ici
2024 500 nouveaux logements devraient
être sortis de terre débuté en août 2020
le chantier de la zac de la remise se
poursuit à voisins le bretonneux
ce futur éco quartier situé en plein
coeur de la ville s'étendra sur 10 à 12
hectares
c'est un quartier qui va répondre aux
besoins de notre commune avec une
typologie de logement assez variés on
aura aussi bien du logement social de
l'accession aidée de l'accession libre
du logement locatif intermédiaire
donc on va voir tous les types de
produits qui peuvent exister une crèche
de 55 berceau en relais d'assistants
maternels un pôle de glisse ou encore
une salle de quartier seront également
créés tout cela avec un objectif le
respect de l'environnement
pour ce faire la rigole qui alimentait
en eau le château de versailles va être
remise en service
on a fait en sorte violent le trait sur
les roses sur les voiries à rénover
toute la partie rigole un eric aux
anciennes donc on va récupérer toutes
les autres pluie tout le pluvial qui
aurait sur les différents lots pour
aller récupérer j'ai un système de nous
ça va alimenter les rigoles qu'on remet
en eau et où le déversement de sirigu
lorsque sont trop rempliront d'iran dans
le bassin de la sueur de rezé un peu
plus loin sa dimitra les effets
inondations et sa part en plus de
remettre en place à ces scènes de
rigoles anciens ce qui compte tout à
fait intéressant les arbres seront
également plantés sur un hectare
autre particularité une église de 800
places va être construite par la
paroisse de montigny voisin coût global
de l'écoquartier 33 millions d'euros et
avant de refermer ce journal je reçoit
en plateau michael demi d'euros bonsoir
soir journalistes de la rédaction tv 78
dans quelques instants vous sera aux
manettes du cetud forces et les missions
de la rédaction pour faire le tour de
l'actualité sportive dans le département
quel est le programme du soir mickaël
alors le programme on va parler
notamment volley ball le club de
conflans andrésy jouy a battu charenton
trois sets à zéro on reviendra sur cette
rencontre
il aura également de l'open de france de
golf qui sera organisée début mai au
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines on y verra
notamment les meilleurs français lors de
cet événement on recevra également en
plateau françois pervis il est dans les
dents les loggias actuellement françois
pervis qui a été cette fois un champion
du monde de cyclisme sur piste qui se
lance dans un tandem avec un malvoyant
voilà on le recevra dans cette émission
il nous parlera de tout cet objectif j
aux paralympiques avec notamment
peut-être une médaille à la clé et on
parlera également de tout ce qui est
sport en en intérieur de ces
actuellement très compliqué pour les
sports à l'intérieur on recevra des
invités également sur la question le 7-8
sport c'est dans un instant sur tv 78
merci michael voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité
très belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]